pour son retour en fédérale 2 plaisir
qui évolue en jaune et bleu avec une
partie compliquée contre bobigny ce
dimanche 17 septembre les plaisirs oies
se sont inclinés sur leur pelouse 47 à
17 en encaissant un terrible 40 à 3 en
première période
c'est une équipe qui a beaucoup de plus
d'expérience que nous au niveau je
rappelle que sedan fédéral une l'année
dernière quand même et c'est vrai que
dès qu'on se consommer un petit peu trop
sur les phases de ruck où six a raté un
plaquage m'a tout de suite ça faisait la
différence ça jouer dans le dos chose
qu'on n'était pas forcément capable de
faire collectivement on était on était
pas mal en place malheureusement
individuellement on a fait vraiment des
grosses fautes de défense
et puis bah face à une très belle équipe
comme ça avec les joueurs rapides qu'ils
avaient forcément on a pris beaucoup
d'essais donc le à la mi-temps ça
faisait cher quand même de retour des
vestiaires le prc a montré un autre
visage devant son public et plaisir on a
marqué deux essais en 40 minutes contre
un essai pour bobigny on vient la
deuxième mi-temps alors après est ce que
on baisser un petit peu le rythme ou ce
qu'ils ont fait tourner au jeu c'est pas
tout cas on a essayé de montrer un peu
plus fière allure
bon ben du coup ça a payé il faut
s'offrir sans s'accrocher à ce à quoi il
faudra s'inspirer de cette seconde
période dès dimanche prochain plaisir se
déplacera sur le terrain de drancy une
équipe qui a déjà engrangé une victoire
dans ce championnat de fédérale 2